a consolidated view of what a superbug
is is a species of bacteria that we're
familiar with that we're aware of that
takes on an additional characteristic
that rather abruptly and suddenly makes
it far less easy to address than it used
to be but we've heard that connotation
tagged to different bacteria over time
and while they have been very big
problems things like mrs a or
methicillin-resistant Staph aureus we've
been able to come up with solutions I do
think there are some potential super bug
problems that we need to be aware of
though a you know sort of a generic
description would be a very common
bacteria that not only becomes resistant
to most of the antibiotics that are
normally used for it but that becomes
much more aggressive in terms of how
quickly it goes from an initial
infection to putting the patient in a
very precarious position so when those
kind of events happen that's when the
medical community i think is quite off
guard with respect to what it's dealing
with and one of the challenges then is
what is that gap in time between when we
become aware of that problem and when
we're able to deliver a solution so yeah
there are things like that that keep us
on our toes